[Music]
welcome back to careful boys
we're so careful and we have a girl
today
thanks for having me yeah your first
time on the careful show it's it's well
the second time on careful show but
that's okay
so first we're very safe here yeah i
like i feel safe it's a safe place we
just want to empower people here yeah
you know what i mean we're very
empowering
some might say we're very awake
we're very awake we're not woke
but we're no no no but we're awake
that's past times dude we don't want
that woke is like you just woke up awake
is like you've been awake yeah you've
been awake we've been here woke is like
you're still groggy and you're kind of
getting a grasp of reality but awake is
like man
i've been alive you have a third eye
yeah
i got another eye through my rectum too
i see from front and back what have you
been seeing lately now that you can see
front and back well he's probably seen
like the inside of his boxers
i gotta take out the lens first you
don't wear boxers don't wear boxers
that's true i don't really wear
underwear wait really dangerous thing
you've recently done uh the most
dangerous thing as a careful girl
instantly done
honestly i think it's just drive i'm not
the greatest driver if i'm gonna be
honest are you
so scared are you a talker and swayer i
love how careful am i a what a talker
and swayer that's a that's me like
i was like look straight because as i'm
talking about oh [ __ ]
i do that because i like to engage so
she's like stop [ __ ] looking at me
i need to i need to see your reactions
and see what's going on you're [ __ ]
menacing i am somebody who will get lost
in a conversation or in a song and just
miss all my exits that's me
i think missing exits it's okay
but bart drifts through different lanes
when he's engaged in conversation but i
get bounced back
i don't go over i don't go like dude
like over and over if cars are animals
on the freeway you're like riding an
elephant though you can't be [ __ ]
drifting with it bart is a horrible
driver though dude his truck is so i
don't like how you guys are perpetuating
the stereotype hey you're a good driver
yeah thank you bart's a horrible [ __ ]
driver
i'm like a good bad driver because like
i break a lot of laws but i do it
intentionally
rules are meant to be broken
i speed i drive a i drive against
traffic or like yeah i drive over curves
and things like that but it was
intentional i meant to do it i've never
been in the car for that yeah so i
rescinded when i said that's you're a
horrible driver thank you yeah joe was a
very good driver i've been in the car
with you very safe very safe very alert
he looks over his shoulders a lot and i
don't know how cause i'm still atd bart
just guns it in the next lane
and he's like nobody's going this fast
he says good luck everybody else
i think we were talking about how steve
wrecked us oh yeah [ __ ] that's a
dangerous thing is we invested into
crypto with this [ __ ] scam artist i'm
a scam artist oh my god and i hate that
we just keep making money with this con
artist no he's actually wrecking he's
just steve is genuinely wrecked yeah how
to you wrecked your rectum
you high you sell high no you buy
sellers i solo a lot okay i've gotten
into a number of things i've swear
scouts on it i've gone to a number of
things that steve has talked about yeah
i could take some blame but that's not
the point of this video but it takes
some blame yeah that's not the focus
here the focus is i wouldn't have known
about these all coins and stuff like
that if it wasn't for steve but you got
significantly wrecked because of uh when
you bought them it's not again it's not
about me here yeah it's i wouldn't have
known about these and i got wrecked and
i bought them and i lost money and it's
your fault which one did you buy that's
not the point and when what did you
what's the point then
okay did you sell during this recent dip
you want shoes all right you want to
choose okay let's talk let's talk choose
what i lose money on on steve's
recommendation let's talk [ __ ] truths
here okay guy let's talk lto
let's talk api three lto network what
the [ __ ] are these ones just calm down
just calm down
api three he never told me to buy any of
those
again it's not about me
uh what else did i lose money on a
number of for sure a lot of things
i'm not going to talk about him making
me a [ __ ] ton more money than i lost
that's not the point the point is how
steve wrecked us well because you so you
like the way he wrecked his
cryptocurrencies that [ __ ] mess steve
makes me lose that made their first six
figures in their whole entire lives well
steve also made me a lot of money but
that's not the purpose of this video we
could do that in another video about how
c [ __ ] so because you put clay money
into lto network which uh which did not
perform as well as some other things
that you put here you're having to wait
like four years on it and it's only been
like three months but sure i can
understand why i've lost money i
remember in one way but you [ __ ] did
that to me i got you i got you okay so
like everybody who's out there who's on
reddit or in the comments talking about
steve i i
relate and i want you what are we gonna
give steve when we make i mean when we
lose more money
we're gonna give him stuff because we
lost more money dude you got so wrecked
that you brought some don julio 1942
today don't bring that up right now dude
we're on camera oh because because you
got so very red yeah yeah i'm i'm i have
no money yeah um when it's not so good
for you and it's a bad time for all of
us that's the point i think the point is
that like
the real the real reason why we even
brought this conversation up is because
we want to just like let the people out
there that feel a certain way about
steve know that they're right yeah
they're so right and i sold my car for
crypto that's a very desperate move by
the way yeah the point is you sell your
car because you don't have any money
you're not worthless he steve's homeless
he can't even afford a sandwich are all
these people that hate on you for your
crypto genius what's wrong with them i
don't even know
this guy just cuts cuts my [ __ ]
right away because i'm like why like why
do people jump the gun they don't even
know what the [ __ ] going on because
it's so wrong that he's out here trying
to give uh i guess advice i understand
my credentials are that i i did comedy
on youtube i'm a youtube comedian yeah
he doesn't have a degree in cryptometry
couldn't know how this stuff works or
how how to do it i couldn't have a group
of people my crypto corner people that
i'm making six figures and been crushing
it you know it's probably not yeah not
realistic do you think people who are
obviously
winning and coming up off of your advice
are talking to you
well then no they are it's become a game
why are they paying attention like god
damn it six figures you don't know [ __ ]
steve how would they know the best thing
is the people so and i generally do feel
bad for for some of these folks because
though they're watching like the price
of me and joe's coin like luna
when it dipped to five bucks and they're
going
and joe got wrecked and they knew about
this project at five they could have
bought it too and then been part of the
price action only after 40 [ __ ] five
bucks but instead they're just like haha
these guys suck they're lo they lose
it's it's like it's more important to be
like haha you you failed rather than
like
oh [ __ ] yeah come along for the ride and
yeah we all could have won together
everyone wins together people some
people don't want to win though they
just want to laugh at other people yeah
and they don't want other people to win
because that makes them feel want you to
win yeah they lost in game they were
never playing but they want to laugh
while in the loser corner yeah you know
i mean that's so weird because he gave
out this
information like
ages ago and everyone had the
opportunity to buy it at five or even
when we were when you and i were talking
about buying bitcoin for our money
masters we were talking about buying
bitcoin and ethereum when it was it was
like three thousand dollars yeah bitcoin
was three thousand ethereum was under a
hundred yeah like the multiples are
[ __ ] insane oh
the bear market's when you're supposed
to be buying the most but then the
people who got conned by us and they
were listening to you know
us at that time what ended up happening
is they put you know they're they're a
couple of hundred and maybe a thousand
dollars into it and oh well now they're
five figures plus yeah my dm's are
horrible dudes i know um people
like my like miranda who's part of my my
crypto group she's like yeah i was
watching money masters i put in money
and it's been insane she got scammed
again huh insane's a bad word by the way
that's when someone's saying they need
to go to a mental asylum because
sometimes you know when you make
when you make too much money
you don't know what to do hey and money
you know your family can turn on you
about money there's all kinds of more
money more problems right and that's
what it really is that's the real sad
part yeah semi serious for a moment take
out the crypto variable in general and
it's like no one who's [ __ ] happy or
successful
is gonna spend time in comments talking
[ __ ] on somebody else oh no no one who's
killing the game even if somebody was
scamming or lying or like not doing as
well if you were [ __ ] killing the
game you wouldn't waste that much time
getting on and trying to like bring
other people down you know what i'm
saying i see bart do it all the time
bart's always biting people in the
comments does it from his house to his
neighbors bart's like your house is
small and they're like it's literally
the same neighborhood it's a [ __ ]
copy of your house
we all have the same house here your
house is small that's what he said he
says it's small from this angle though
[Laughter]
he's wearing a shirt that says dominate
humbly i could cover it i cover with my
thumb yeah you can cover their house
without you can crush it
humbly if you walk far enough you can't
cover the house yeah you can just go
like this yeah it's close
be quiet you know what though his house
is empty
oh it's so big it's hard to fill it up
he has no furniture no
he's got all these extra beds and [ __ ]
oh and by the way his guest room's
comfortable dude man i slept like a baby
yeah today's video is brought to you by
feels cbd isn't about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as
stress anxiety pain
oh my goodness
you know what i'm addicted to what
caffeine
yeah that's kind of like my theme that i
go to anytime i feel like a little bit
down then i used caffeine to help keep
me awake take a nap i know but sometimes
you have time that's true so like this
uh just two days ago when i came here
from vegas i woke up at three because
you know we left at 5am but i wanted to
get in a workout before i even get on
the road because i know once i get here
i have so many errands i have to do i
don't have time so i'm up at three and i
take a pre-workout wait you're working
out when i was over at your house yeah i
was working out i didn't even hear you i
tried to be quiet oh that was like
squatting quietly and then so i i have
uh maybe 300 350 milligrams of caffeine
we got we went to the gas station i love
gas station coffee yup probably another
100 milligrams of caffeine that was some
good coffee though it was i got to the
office i had a media another 100
milligrams caffeine
so and then i probably had two more cups
of like cold brew so by the time it's at
night wow i'm exhausted but you know
when you're still on a caffeine high
like you're still like whoa what the
hell is going on yeah so the only thing
that helps me
take the throttle off of that caffeine
is feels because that kind of i feel
like it helps me adjust a little bit and
it helps me relax and soothe and i can
finally go to sleep because the last
thing you want is when you're really
tired but you close your eyes and you
still can't sleep yeah so that's what i
like feels for
and it's pretty easy to use too because
you just get the feels put a few drops
on the tip of your tongue and you just
wait for the effects to go but also if
your first time you don't know what to
do it's awesome because fields has its
own personal hotline that you can call
in and be like hey i don't know how many
i'm about to feel with this i don't know
give me can give me like some kind of
dosage and they'll help
walk you through the whole process so
you don't have to feel like such a noob
about it so you can become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and you get 50 off your
first order plus free shipping that's f
e a l s dot com slash off the record
become a member today and get 50 percent
off plus free shipping
do you guys feel like we happen to just
be living in like uh this like new age
digital world where everybody has so
much access to anything like anything
whether it's right or wrong information
but at the same time it's also kind of
this
unique generation of information where
anybody who comes from comedy can
suddenly be like a crypto wizard and and
be very very successful or anybody who
comes from nothing can suddenly
overnight like learn a craft and become
like an expert in non-traditional ways
that like people have been used to
therefore like people are struggling
with the growing pains of our generation
you know what i'm saying for sure 100
there's people that are experts in like
a year at things because the the the
access to information and then how often
you can repeat things and and learn and
practice yeah cause you were showing me
the [ __ ] uh kids practicing a new
fighting style there's a new fighting
style being created that i didn't think
was even possible and it's like people
can get
so much what was the announcement oh
yeah you the dude who came from barbell
the 19 year old or some show what is his
name damian yeah and he's like [ __ ]
deadlifts 650 yeah when he was like 13
or something now he like is a [ __ ]
canadian champion or some [ __ ] but is a
canadian champion that good though yeah
he is canadian
anything that's canadian doesn't feel
that official i don't like haters though
yeah just to be honest yeah
yeah
canadian champion
oh but you know what drake is quite the
champion in the hip-hop world who is
drake is quite the champion in the in
the hip-hop world and so is the biebers
but i feel like what happens is that
they become american exactly you forget
we adopted them that's really what it is
yeah when you get big enough you stop
representing canada i used to like drake
but then i saw nicki minaj give him a
lap dance in the anaconda music video
and i was like [ __ ] this guy you got
jealous a little bit no no
that sounds like a hater to me man what
happened to you i just don't like that i
don't like that yeah yeah come on man we
need to get some humble juice in you
it's not even that good actually gotta
go to humboldt county dude he's onto
degrassi he's not that good your point
anthony i also think in this digital age
i think uh because you have so it's so
easy to express yourself
most of the foster used to happen in
here and you have a chance to challenge
your own thoughts play be your own
devil's advocate critically think gather
more information and then have a
conclusion
uh and then you put something out there
that's a little bit has more foundation
and the last test of time people are
putting their inside thoughts on the
outside that's what twitter is so
there's like people that aren't even
doing devil's advocate or any like
people before people could even go wait
so
maybe steve has as much passion for
comedy as he does for crypto and he does
a lot of studying
no [ __ ] all that stuff that usually
takes time they're just going ste don't
know [ __ ]
until they get owned and then he has all
these six figure people in this corner a
lot of people are renaissance people you
know like russell peters he's a [ __ ]
jiu jitsu guy like i mean there's like
comedy dj yeah yeah he does dj yeah
but a lot of people have the ability to
do a lot of things well you know no such
thing as a lane for you anymore like one
thing yeah one has like several things
they can do and i think a lot of people
have issue with that except in that
transitionary period like anthony was
saying of like oh you can do whatever it
is you want and it's up to you because
some people won't take the shots that
they need to do that they need to take
in order to get to where they want to be
they just see someone that they think
ain't [ __ ] doing what they want to do
they're like oh why can't i do that
so they have a hard time processing i do
think though that i probably and this
sounds like i'm actually honest i do
think i probably went a little too hard
on crypto as far as the amount of
information that i read about crypto and
[ __ ] like sometimes i can be in a
conversation it doesn't always happen
but sometimes i'm like i feel
uncomfortable in this conversation
because it's not about crypto you know
what i'm saying like that can happen to
me because i just went so [ __ ] nuts
so you miss it like you're addicted to
it like you're obsessed yeah i got
obsessed with it for sure but that's how
hobbies and passions and
things happen right and that's how you
get good at things that's how you get
good and that's also how you do
phenomenal things this is different
right it's like i was just having this
conversation last night but
only crazy people are capable of doing
crazy things take good or bad or right
or wrong or morality whatever get that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of there and only focus
on the idea if you're a [ __ ] average
person you're not going to do a
phenomenal thing you have to you're
gonna do an average thing yeah yeah you
have to be a crazy person to do a crazy
thing whether good or bad and it's like
that's what it takes you know i mean to
be honest like everybody here probably
has some sort of like obsession
unhealthy healthy who cares whatever
whether it be fighting working now
crypto whatever it is but that's what
enables us to get to a place of either
magnitude or
i don't know [ __ ] talking failure call
it what you want you know what i'm
saying it's like people need to get
crazy or psycho if you want to be able
to do something crazy you can't sit on
the sidelines and just comment about
[ __ ] and not take the daredevil step and
expect the daredevil reward you know
what i mean yes that's all true yeah
that's very true
that was very profound and we have
nothing to say because of that i like
that you dropped the marvel superhero
that i knew about in that speech too
daredevil steps oh daredevil who wants a
daredevil
[Laughter]
[ __ ] in there he's like i watch
daredevil like this
so i can relate to him he's dc though
yeah they all look like daryl their
devils dc nah no that's marvel but dead
trucks
people still ask me today about like
jumping on the money masters and all
that and i'm like sorry we discontinued
that man yeah but you could go join
crypto corner with steve and all that
stuff but
i don't know this day and age it's kind
of like there's so much info right but i
also know that with that in fitness and
finance and all these things there's
also a lot of cons there's also a lot of
snake oil like you just don't know and
then there were um a lot of youtube
channels like a couple years ago that
was coming out and they were dedicated
on just
calling out
online scams that's a new genre in of
itself it's like
i i have a guilty pleasure of going on
youtube and watching like gossip
channels about tick-tockers who were
like so much younger than me because i
just think like this high school drama
is like funny yeah and
they're they will make whole careers out
of reporting what someone like what
shady uh gossip will be going on i mean
that was dramaalert yeah yeah it's like
a whole genre in of itself where they
get 200 000 views on a video they're
bigger creators than some of these tick
talkers are talking about dude i was at
a youtube meeting where they brought
like everybody like a bunch of people i
don't know how i got in that room i
didn't really deserve to be right
because it was like the fine brothers
all these big guys but friends of mine
good dudes but they were saying like
everyone in the room was like bitching
because all the drama channels were
basically the top 100 now like getting
all the yeah like four years ago they
got they were the top and the biggest
complaint was why are you guys
like basically encouraging this because
it's like the tmz and the your algorithm
is favoring it and they're basically
like making a career off of like
literally [ __ ] on other tubers and
[ __ ] yeah which is fine but that was one
of the biggest complaints and youtube
was just like
okay we're hearing you today we're
literally going to do nothing
it's
about
it's it's fascinating but it's also like
what the audience wanted man like they
love they click on it humans love gossip
and drama yeah they just i think like
that was like yeah like 30 40 of human
conversation is that look at the grocery
store aisle bro with the the daily star
and all the i know the
[ __ ] shitty mags it was like meghan
markle's is having a [ __ ] alien baby
people got a gossip did you see megan
merkel on the beach and like look at the
cellulite on her thighs it's like jesus
dudes she is so you like no i'm just you
know i don't know the queen of england
is immortal or some [ __ ] you know
that is interesting as [ __ ] though i
gotta admit it is pretty funny but i
guess like i think there's a part of
something about being human is like
talking [ __ ] or or you're talking about
others people need to know who's shady
or not like that's what gossip is it's
it's communicating like oh yo this is
fun as [ __ ] gossip it's fun as [ __ ] like
not talking [ __ ] on somebody to
perpetuate harm against another person
but to enhance joy
right i mean that's [ __ ] we all do it in
some way shape joy maker goes up yeah
yeah so i guess you know i guess i'll go
full circle retract everything i said
everybody's hating in the comments like
yo you do you
honestly keep coming that's the truest
[ __ ] cuz like there's you know
especially like the fitness space
there's like um there's people that want
to go science based and there's people
that want to go more of the fluff to me
i'm like dude whatever works works it
all works so today i saw a post where
it's like buy a couple of md fitness
guys and they were like uh you know when
the personal trainer tells the mom when
the 20 year old personal trainer tells
the mom that you only everyone has the
same 24 hours in the day it's like well
sometimes you know you have more
obligation and that's not true but i'm
like dude that's like the most literal
way of taking it yes the mom probably
doesn't have the same 24 hours but
that's also the same thing as going like
if your basketball coach said everyone i
want you to give your 110 percent you
know well excuse me that's impossible to
go over a hundred percent you know i'm
like sometimes that mom needs that extra
motivation and maybe that's what they're
leaning on and they're not leaning on
like the the logical part of it is it's
scientifically possible
to go over 100 you know what i mean i
just think like if something is put out
there if it works for you take it and
let it work it doesn't have to be judged
like what's really right or what's
really wrong yeah there's no there's no
real standard that everyone [ __ ]
follows the rules everything's
subjective you know like someone like
placebo effect works something like it
obviously is a hoax but if it works for
you [ __ ] it but i will say if you're not
getting hate
you're not killing the game hard enough
that's true especially if you feel
hey you made it you're killing it bro
because it's [ __ ] though not because
luna's only at 40 bucks right now
let's go baby we're doing like [ __ ] oh
40.
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you